ASSEMBLY MEMBER LORD RECOGNIZES
THE ABSENCE OF A QUORUM THE
SERGEANTS AT ARMS WILL PREPARE
THE CHAMBER AND BRING IN THE
ABSENT MEMBERS THE CLERK WILL
CALL THE ROLL AGUIAR-CURRY.
ARAMBULA BARRICADE IN BENNETT
BERMAN BIGELOW BLOOM
BOERNER HORVATH BONTA BRIAN
CALDERON LEO CERVANTES GEN SURE
COOLEY COOPER CUNNINGHAM DALY
DALY DAVIES FLORA MIKE FONG
VINCE FONG FRIEDMAN GABRIEL
GALLAGHER CRISTINA GARCIA
EDUARDO GARCIA GIPSON GRAY.
GRAYSON HOLDEN IRWIN JONES
SAWYER KALRA. KILEY BLACKY LOUIS
LEVINE LOW MAIENSCHEIN MATHIS
MAYES MCCARTY MEDINA MULLIN
MURATSUCHI NAZARIAN NGUYEN
DONALD PATTERSON PETRIE-NORRIS
QUOTE QUIRK-SILVA RAMOS REYES
LOOSE REBAJAS ROBERT RIVAS
RODRIGUEZ RUBIO SALAS SANTIAGO
SEYARTO SMITH. STONE TAKING
BALLOT ERRORS V. APPROVED LAW
VOEPEL WALDRON WARD WEBER WICKS
WOOD MISTER SPEAKER.
MEMBERS A QUORUM IS PRESENT WE
ASK OUR GUESTS AND VISITORS IN
THE REAR OF THE CHAMBER AND IN
THE GALLERY TO PLEASE STAND FOR
THE PRAYER THE DAYS PRAYER WILL
BE OFFERED BY OUR ASSEMBLY
CHAPLAIN IMAM YES HERE. THE
MONEY AFTER. IN THE NAME OF GOD
THE MOST GRACIOUS THE MOST
MERCIFUL. ALMIGHTY GOD WE
ACKNOWLEDGE THAT YOUR MERCY IS
GREAT. AND IT COVERS A MULTITUDE
OF OUR SHORTCOMINGS. YOUR
STEADFAT LOVE IS FOR EACH ONE.
AND IS UNCONDITIONALLY AVAILABLE
TO ALL. THEREFORE OH GOD WE SEEK
YOUR GUIDANCE IN OUR WORK AND
OUR WORDS WE NEED YOUR WISDOM
FOR OUR DEBATES AND OUR
DECISIONS. AND WE HUMBLY PRAY
FOR PEACE IN OUR TIME FOR PEACE
IN OUR COMMUNITY. AND FOR PEACE
IN OUR WORLD I MEAN. THANK YOU
MOM WE ASK OUR GUESTS AND
VISITORS TO REMAIN STANDING AND
JOIN US FOR THE FLAG SALUTE
PLEASE JOIN ASSEMBLY MEMBER
RUBIO AS HE LEADS US IN THE
PLEDGE. THANK YOU MADAM SPEAKER
PLEASE JOIN ME IN THE FLAG
SALUTE READY BEGIN. I PLEDGE
ALLEGIANCE TO THE FLAG. ONE YOU
MAY BE SEATED. READING OF THE
PREVIOUS DAY'S JOURNAL ASSEMBLY
SERVER SACRAMENTO MONDAY
FEBRUARY FOURTEENTH TWENTY
TWENTY TWO THESE FROM THE BED AT
ONE PM THE AUDIBLE KEVIN MULLIN
SPEAKER PRO TEMPORE PIECE OF THE
PRESIDING T. FLEXI PROGRAMS. MR
GALLAGHER SECONDS AT THE READING
OF THE PREVIOUS DAY'S JOURNAL.
BE DISPENSED WITH PRESENTATIONS
AND PETITIONS THERE ARE NONE.
INTRODUCTION AND REFERENCE IT OF
BILLS WILL BE DEFERRED. REPORTS
OF COMMITTEES WILL BE DEEMED
READ AND AMENDMENTS DEEMED
ADOPTED. MESSAGES FROM THE
GOVERNOR THERE ARE NONE MESSAGES
FROM THE SENATE THERE ARE NONE.
MOVING ON TO MOTIONS AND
RESOLUTIONS. THERE ARE THREE
EXCUSED ABSENCES TODAY FOR
ILLNESS ASSEMBLY MEMBER COURT
ASSEMBLY MEMBER WALDRON AND
ASSEMBLY MEMBER FLORA FOR
PATERNITY LEAVE ASSEMBLY MEMBER
ME. THIS REYES YOU'RE RECOGNIZED
FOR YOUR PROCEDURAL MOTIONS
THANK YOU MA'AM SPEAKER I
REQUEST UNANIMOUS CONSENT TO
SUSPEND ASSEMBLY RULE FORTY FIVE
POINT FIVE HELLO ASSEMBLY MEMBER
TEAM TO SPEAK ON AND
ADJOURNMENTS IN MEMORY TODAY.
WITHOUT OBJECTION SUCH SHALL BE
THE ORDER. I REQUEST UNANIMOUS
CONSENT TO SUSPEND ASSEMBLY RULE
ONE EIGHTEEN EIGHTY HELLO
ASSEMBLY MEMBER COOLEY TO HAVE
GUESTS AND PHOTOGRAPHERS ON THE
FLOOR TODAY. WITHOUT OBJECTION
SUCH SHALL BE THE ORDER. I
REQUEST UNANIMOUS CONSENT TO
SUSPEND THE RULES TO ALLOW
ASSEMBLY MEMBER COOLEY TO TAKE
UP HR NINETY FOUR TODAY WITHOUT
REFERENCE TO FILE FOR THE
PURPOSE OF ADOPTION. WITHOUT
OBJECTION SUCH SHALL BE THE
ORDER. MOVING ONTO GUEST
INTRODUCTIONS MEMBERS WE HAVE
GUESTS WITH US IN THE ASSEMBLY
TODAY. MR COOLEY. YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED AND MR MULLINS DESK.
GOOD MORNING COLLEAGUES. IS A
VERY GREAT PLEASURE TODAY TO
INTRODUCE THE GENTLEMAN TO MY
LEFT MISTER DICK MCCARTHY WHO
HAS SERVED FOR DECADES AS A
CHIEF EXECUTIVE OFFICER OF THE
CALIFORNIA STATE SEISMIC SAFETY
COMMISSION. IT'S ONE OF THE
PECULIARITIES OF MY LIFE THAT I
ACTUALLY TOUCHED YEARS RIVER OF
QUICK OF PUBLIC POLICY. FOR THE
FIRST TIME BACK IN SEVENTY SIX.
I'VE HAD A PRIVILEGE TO WORK
WITH ALL OF THE EXECUTIVE
DIRECTORS OF THE STATE SIDE OF
CITY COMMISSION. DICK ANDREWS
TOM TOBIN ADDICT MCCARTY BUT
DICK MCCARTY IS. SURPASSED THEM
ALL IN HIS TENURE. AND A VITAL
ISSUE OF JUST SAFEGUARDING
CALIFORNIA DISAPPEAR OVER A
QUICK. EVEN THAT LITTLE PIECE OF
MY LIFE WHICH I'M SO BUSY WITH
THAT CAUSE US ALL TO MOVE LAST
FALL IS BECAUSE IN APRIL OF
EIGHTEEN NINETY TWO THERE ARE
SIX POINT FOUR EARTHQUAKES TWO
OF THEM TWO DAYS APART THIRTY
MILES AWAY FROM US HERE IN THE
STATE CAPITAL WHICH WE OFTEN
THINK OF. AS SEISMICALLY STABLE
. SO I'M VERY HONORED TO.
INTRODUCED TECH MCCARTY WHO IS
ACTUALLY SIR FORTY TWO YEARS- AS
- EXAGRID RECTOR OF THE OFFER
THE ALCOA SIDE OF SAFETY
COMMISSION. AND DICK IS A
GEOLOGIST BY TRAINING- AND SO MY
STAFF WANTS ME TO SAY WHEN IT
COMES TO GEOLOGY INSIDER STUFF
HE ROCKS HIS SUBJECTS SO THAT
THERE'S A GEOLOGY JOE. THERE HE
HAS A MASTER'S AND BACHELOR OF
SCIENCE DEGREE IN GEOLOGY FROM
SAID IN THE STATE UNIVERSITY. HE
IS ALSO A CERTIFIED ENGINEER AND
PETROLEUM GEOLOGIST. AND HOLDS A
CALIFORNIA TEACHING CREDENTIAL
SO A LOT OF PROFESSIONAL BAND
WITH IN OUR DECK MCCARTY WHEN WE
ARE HERE TODAY. HE'S DEVOTED HIS
WHOLE AND WHOLE LIFE TO PUBLIC
SERVICE. OUR PRIOR TO JOINING
THE SIDE OF STATE SECURITY
ACTUALLY WORKED AS A SENIOR
ENGINEERING GEOLOGIST FOR THE
CALIFORNIA COASTAL COMMISSION.
FROM SEVENTY NINE TO NINETEEN
NINETY. AND SO THAT WAS IN THE
EARLY YEARS OF THE SEISMIC
SAFETY COMMISSION OR THE
CALIFORNIA COASTAL COMMISSION.
HE ALSO SERVED AS A STAFF CDVA
GEOLOGIST FOR THE FEW GROW
ENERGY COMPANY IN LONG BEACH.
AND IN THAT ROLE HE PARTICIPATED
IN THE IDENTIFICATION OF NUCLEAR
POWER PLANT SITES IN CALIFORNIA.
ALSO IN ARIZONA AND PORTER RICO.
AND THAT PUT HI ON A LOT OF
PEOPLE'S RADAR SCREEN BECAUSE OF
HIS PROFESSIONAL COMPETENCIES.
UP ON JULY TWENTY FIFTH NINETEEN
NINETY SIX THAT'S WHEN HE TOOK
ON THE MOST IMPORTANT ROLE OF
HIS CAREER. BECOME EXECUTIVE
DIRECTOR OF THE SIZE OF STATE TO
COMMISSION. DURING HIS TENURE
THERE HE HAS WORKED ASSIDUOUSLY.
TO REDUCE EARTHQUAKE LOSSES BY
PROVIDED COST EFFECTIVE
SOLUTIONS. TO INVESTIGATIONS AND
RESEARCH AND OF COURSE. THE.
UNIQUE FEATURE THE SIZE ARE SAFE
TO CONVERT IT IS A BASED PANEL.
A GREAT ARRAY PER X. SO THAT TOO
MANY LENSES DEAL WITH MULTI
FACET ISSUE OVER. ALWAYS FOCUS
ON HOW DO WE MAKE CALIFORNIA
MORE EARTHQUAKE SAFE. AND IT IS
VERY UNIQUE IN STATE GOVERNMENT
BECAUSE THERE'S BROAD BASED
COLLECTIVE. WORKING TOGETHER. SO
I JUST WANT TO ASK US ALL IF YOU
WOULD JOIN ME FOR ALL RISE IN
HONOR OF DICK MCCARTY. WHO WITH
HIS WEALTH OF DOLLARS OFFICE
ABOVE ALL KINDNESS. HAS
SUCCEEDED IN PUBLIC SERVICE
ENTERS NOW AND RETIREMENT- AND
OF DICK WE JUST I ADMIRE YOU A
GREAT DEAL. DECADES OF SERVICE
IN THIS FIELD SO I'M PRETTY
HAPPY WITH THIS. RESOLUTION ARE
HONORING YOU AND I HASTEN TO
POINT OUT IT IS- WE ARE JOINED
IN THIS BY JOHN WILL ADAM GRAY
WHO FOR SO LONG CHAIRED THE GEO
COMMITTEE AND THIS BODY. OF MR
KEVIN KILEY MY COLLEAGUES- WHO-
VISIT YOUR HOME MR DURING HIS
ARIAN WHO'S VERY ACTIVE ON
SEISMIC ISSUES AS WE ALL KNOW.
AND MIGUEL SANTIAGO- SO YEAH.
THANK RECONNOITER VENTURE. THIS.
CAN GO. TO MR MCKAY.
MEMBERS WE HAVE ADDITIONAL
GUESTS IN THE GALLERY. ON BEHALF
OF SPEAKER RENDON WE WOULD LIKE
TO WELCOME MEMBERS OF THE
CALIFORNIA CONTRACT CITIES
ASSOCIATION WELCOME TO THE
ASSEMBLY. MEMBERS WE HAVE
UPCOMING BIRTHDAYS THIS
WEEKEND'S SUNDAY MARCH SIXTH THE
IN ASSEMBLY MEMBERS ASSEMBLY
MEMBER SANTIAGO'S BIRTHDAY
PLEASE JOIN ME WISHING
ASSEMBLYMEMBER SANTIAGO AYE
HAPPY BIRTHDAY.
MEMBERS ASSEMBLY MEMBER COOLEY
HAS BEEN GRANTED PERMISSION TO
TAKE UP HR NINETY FOUR WITHOUT
REFERENCE TO FILE. THIS IS A
RULES COMMITTEE REPORT AT THE
DESK THAT WILL BE DEEMED READ
AND ADOPTED. THE CLRK WILL READ
H. R. NINETY FOUR WITH THE
PURPOSE OF ADOPTION. HOUSE WAS
LUCIA NINETY FOUR BY ASSEMBLY
MEMBER COOLEY AND OTHERS
RELATIVE TO UKRAINE. ASSEMBLY
MEMBER COOLEY. ASSEMBLY MEMBER
TO EUROPE THE BEST. CALL IS THE
PURPOSE OF THIS IS TO PRESENT A
RESOLUTION REGARDING THE
SITUATION IN UKRAINE. THIS GREAT
CIRCUMSTANCE AFFECTING THE
PEOPLE YOU CRAM AFFECTED LOCAL.
AND I GOT TO PUT IN PERSPECTIVE
YOU KNOW WORDS MULTIPLY ON THIS
FLOOR. AND SOME WORDS ARE
ESPECIALLY IMPORTANT AND RICH IN
THEIR MEANING. WE START OUR
SESSIONS WITH. I PLEDGE
ALLEGIANCE TO THE FLAG. AND I
KNOW THAT TOUCHES EACH ONE OF
OUR HEARTS. OUR NATIONAL ANTHEM
- SAY CAN YOU SEE THIS FOR YOU
YOU KNOW FRANCIS SCOTT KEY WROTE
THAT HE WAS LOOKING AT HER WAS
APPROVAL FAR HE WAS LOOKING AT
THAT FORTRESS THROUGH THE NIGHT
BOMB BLAST WENT OFF AND SEE THAT
THE FLAG WAS STILL THERE. OUR
NATIONAL ANTHEM STIRS OUR HEARTS
AND IT IS WORDS OF TERRORISM
FROM AFAR. IN HISTORY AND IN
SPACE. AND I SAY THIS BECAUSE I
WANT YOU TO REFLECT FOR A MOMENT
. AS I TAKE UP THIS RESOLUTION.
ON THE OPENING LINE. OF THE
UKRAINIAN NATIONAL ANTHEM. WHAT
DID THEY CONJURE UP. TO BE THE
OPENING LINE. OF THEIR NATIONAL
ANTHEM. GLORY N. FREEDOM OF
UKRAINE. HAS NOT YET PARISHED.
THESE ARE POWERFUL WORDS TO
REFLECT UPON A PEOPLE FIGHTING
FOR THEIR LIVES. AND YET THOSE
ARE THE WORDS THAT. FIND THEIR
HEARTS TOGETHER. CONVEY THEIR
SENSE OF THEIR FUTURE THEIR
PURPOSE. SO COLLEAGUES I AM
HONORED TODAY I REPRESENT REALLY
HERE SECOND ACCOUNTED THE
LARGEST DIASPORA OF UKRAINIAN.
EMIGRES IN THE WORLD AS WE IN
CALIFORNIA DO. BUT IS A VERY
VERY LARGE POPULATION HERE AND
BACK IN. NINETEEN TWO THOUSAND
FOURTEEN WHEN THEY STARTED
SENDING TRUCKLOADS OF
PERISHABLES AND FOOD UKRAINE
BECAUSE THIS SAME POWER WAS
ENCROACHING AND US AND OUR LAND
I WAS HONORED TO JOIN WITH MY
COMMUNITY AND DO THE RIBBON
CUTTING FOR THAT FIRST TRUCK.
BUT THIS IS A VAST COMMUNITY IN
OUR STATE. AND CERTAINLY HERE A
SECOND A COUNTY. MR KILEY IN MY
DISTRICT TOGETHER. ON FEBRUARY
TWENTY FOUR TWENTY TWENTY TWO
RUSSIAN INVADED ITS NEIGHBOR
UKRAINE THREATENED OUR
DEMOCRATICALLY ELECTED
GOVERNMENT IN ATTACK THE
VIOLATES THE RULE OF LAW.
NATIONAL SOVEREIGNTY AND FREEDOM
MAKHOSI. AND AS A FREELY ELECTED
DEMOCRACY UKRAINE AND PRESERVE.
ZIELINSKI SHERMAN AT THE SAME
DEMOCRATIC PRINCIPLES WE DO AND
CALIFORNIA AND ARE FIGHTING TO
DEFEND AND PRESERVE THESE IDEALS
. WHICH IS WHY WE RELATE TO THE
OPENING LINE OF THEIR NATIONAL
ANTHEM GLORY AND FREEDOM OF
UKRAINE HAS NOT YET PARRIS. THE
UNITED STATES OUR ALLIES QUICKLY
CONDEMNED THE ACTIONS OF RUSSIAN
PRESIDENT. BUT PUTIN AND
MOBILIZED TO SUPPORT THE PEOPLE
OF UKRAINE. AND HOLDING PRESSURE
GOVERNOR ACCOUNTABLE FOR ITS
AGGRESSION. AND I WANT TO NOTE
THAT THEY'RE JUST A LONG HISTORY
. BEHIND THOSE WORDS. FREEDOM
GLORIA AND FREEDOM OF YOU CAN IS
NOT YET PERISHED. BACK IN
NINETEEN THIRTY TWO. THIS PEOPLE
WERE SUBJECT TO A ORCHESTRATED
FAMINE. WHICH KILLED 25% OF THE
PEOPLE OF RURAL UKRAINE.
REFERRED TO AS THE WHOLE OF THE
MORE A MAN MADE GENOCIDE.
DESPITE IT BEING ONE OF THE MOST
PRODUCTIVE AREAS IN THE THEN
SOVIET UNION. A BREAD BASKET AND
YET PEOPLE DIED. BY A FAMINE.
TWO THOUSAND FOR THE RECRUITING
PEOPLE GAYS IN MASS PROTESTS
AGAINST ELECTORAL FRAUD
CORRUPTION IN EVENT KNOWS YARDS
REVERSES THEIR DEVOTED TO
DEMOCRACY. FLORIAN FREEDOM HAS
NOT YET PERISHED. AGAIN IN
TWENTY FOURTEEN THEY ENGAGE IN
MASS PROTESTS CIVIL DISTURBANCE%
WHEN UNDER PRESSURE FROM RUSSIA
RUSSIA UKRAINIAN GOVERNMENT
SUSPENDED ABOVE TO GO CHANGES
FOR GREATER COOPERATION WITH THE
EUROPEAN UNION THAT'S EVENT AS
DOES THE MEYDAN OR THE REVERSE
OF DIGNITY- SO THIS IS ALL A
PART OF A LONG PATTERN. IN THEIR
WORLD. A PRESSURE OF
INTIMIDATION OF THREAT OF
VIOLENCE AND VIOLENCE IN FACT.
AND THIS IS A PEOPLE. WHO HERE
THERE NATIONAL ANTHEM AND HERE.
GLORY AND FREEDOM OF UKRAINE HAS
NOT YET PARRIS I MONITOR BRING
THIS RESOLUTION BEFORE TODAY. TO
STAND WITH THIS COURAGEOUS
PEOPLE. AGAINST THE PREDATIONS
OF THE PRESENT THE SOVIET UNION
. N. OF. THIRTY SECONDS I
REQUEST YOUR RIVAL. WE'RE.
MISTER BENNETT YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED. THANK YOU VERY MUCH
MADAM CHAIR AND MEMBERS SEVENTY
SEVEN YEARS AGO WORLD WAR TWO
CAME TO AN END. SINCE THEN WE'VE
SADLY SEEN MANY INSTANCES
THROUGHOUT THE WORLD WERE.
RUTHLESS DICTATORS BRUTALLY
ATTACK INNOCENT PEOPLE. TOO MANY
EXAMPLES FAR TOO MANY IN AFRICA
IN THE MIDDLE EAST AND ASIA AND
CENTRAL EUROPE. I THINK WE
SHOULD ASK OURSELVES WHY DOES
THIS PARTICULAR CRISIS IN
UKRAINE RISE TO THE LEVEL WHERE
WE TAKE THE UNUSUAL STEP OF
DOING A RESOLUTION LIKE THIS.
AND I WOULD OFFER TO YOU THAT
THIS IS THE STRONGEST PARALLEL.
TO THE BEGINNING OF WORLD WAR
TWO THAT WE'VE HAD IN THE LAST
SEVENTY SEVEN YEARS. A RUTHLESS
DICTATOR USING FABRICATED STORY
LINES IS ATTACKING A SOVEREIGN
DEMOCRATIC NATION OF BRAVE
INNOCENT PEOPLE IN CENTRAL
EUROPE. PUTIN NOT THE RUSSIAN
PEOPLE PUTIN IS COMPLETELY
TRAMPLING THE INTERNATIONAL
PRINCIPLES OF LAW AND ORDER THAT
HAVE KEPT US FROM HAVING ANOTHER
WORLD WAR IN THE LAST SEVENTY
SEVEN YEARS. THIS WEEK A HUNDRED
AND FORTY ONE YESTERDAY I'M
SORRY A HUNDRED AND FORTY ONE
NATIONS IN THE WORLD LARGE AND
SMALL. ADOPTED A RESOLUTION AT
THE UNITED NATIONS CONDEMNING
PROVEN FOR THIS. BRUTAL INVASION
OF UKRAINE. THOUSANDS OF BRAVE
RUSSIAN CITIZENS ARE PUTTING
THEIR LIVES AT RISK TO TRY TO
PROTEST IN THAT COUNTRY AND OF
COURSE MILLIONS OF BRAVE
UKRAINIANS ARE STANDING THERE
TODAY DEMONSTRATING AND NORMA'S
COURAGE IN ONE OF THE MOST
DESPERATE SITUATIONS A COUNTRY
CAN FIND THEMSELVES IN. AND
SEARCH SEARCH SO IT IS REALLY
APPROPRIATE FOR US. THE
REPRESENTATIVES OF FORTY MILLION
PEOPLE IN CALIFORNIA. THAT WE
SHOULD AT LEAST JOIN THE REST OF
THE WORLD IN CONDEMNING THIS
ATROCIOUS INVASION THAT IS
TAKING PLACE. I BELIEVE THIS IS
ONE ISSUE. THAT ALL OF US
TOGETHER INCOME THAT THAT ALL OF
US CAN COME TOGETHER ON IN THIS
CHAMBER AND I RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR UNANIMOUS VOTE IN SUPPORT OF
THIS RESOLUTION THANK YOU VERY
MUCH. MISTER PATTERSON YOUR
RECOGNIZED AT YOUR DESK. THANK
MEADOW SPEAKER AND A MEMBERS I
RISE IN STRONG SUPPORT. BUT THIS
RESOLUTION AND AS A
REPRESENTATIVE FROM CENTRAL
CALIFORNIA WITH A SIGNIFICANT
UKRAINIAN POPULATION I STAND
WITH THEM AS WELL. BUT LET'S NOT
MAKE ANY MISTAKE ABOUT IT. TODAY
THE RUSSIAN ARMY AT THIS MOMENT
IS COMMITTING WAR CRIMES AND
CRIMES AGAINST HUMANITY. THIS ON
THE DIRECT ORDER. A BLADDER PUT. THE INTERNATIONAL COMMUNITY.
MUST DO SO MUCH MORE THAN
JOINING TOGETHER IN RESOLUTIONS
. WE ARE IN FACT SENDING AID
LEGAL AID. WHICH IS VERY VERY
IMPORTANT. BUT THE INTERNATIONAL
COMMUNITY MUST HOLD VLADIMIR
PUTIN RESPONSIBLE FOR WAR CRIMES
AND CRIMES AGAINST HUMANITY. HE
IS KILLING CIVILIANS HE IS HE
DESTROYING UKRAINIAN CULTURAL
ASSETS. HE IS TARGETING INNOCENT
NONCOMBATANTS. HE MUST BE
INDICTED. BEFORE THE NATIONAL
COURT OF JUSTICE. N. B. HOLD TO
ACCOUNT. FOR HIS CRIMINAL
ACTIONS. HIS CRIMINAL ACTS.
CANNOT BE ALLOWED. EAGLE
CHALLENGE IN THE INTERNATIONAL
COURTS. THE MISTER PUT. WE
CANNOT BE ALLOWED. TO ESCAPE THE
RIGHTEOUS JUDGMENT OF THE LAW.
MISTER LIVIGNO RECOGNIZED. THANK
YOU MADAM SPEAKER I RISE IN
SUPPORT OF HR NINETY FOUR AND I
STAND WITH THE SOVEREIGN
DEMOCRATIC NATION OF UKRAINE AND
ITS PEOPLE AND WANT TO THANK THE
AUTHOR FOR INTRODUCING THIS
RESOLUTION AND FOR BRINGING
ATTENTION TO AN ISSUE THAT I
THINK IS VERY IMPORTANT WHICH IS
THE RECENT ATTACK NEAR THE
HOLOCAUST MEMORIAL AT BABI YAR.
AND IT CALLS ONE OF THE PRE TAX
- INTO TACK ON UKRAINE WHICH WAS
THAT HE NEEDED TO PUSH BACK ON
THE **** THAT AND THE NEO ****
HAVE TAKEN OVER THAT COUNTRY. AT
THE SAME TIME WE KNOW IT'S BEEN
SHARED THAT. THE PRESIDENT OF
UKRAINE IS JEWISH IN FACT THE
PRIME MINISTER OF UKRAINE IS
JEWISH. AND THAT THIS PRETEXT OF
USING THE HOLOCAUST AGAINST
PEOPLE IN EUROPE. AND AGAINST
PEOPLE WHO ARE JEWISH STANDING
UP TO RUSSIA IS ONE OF THE
OLDEST DISEASES OF EUROPE. THAT
WE NEED TO CALL THIS OUT THAT TO
AS NOT KONTRON SKI THE FORMER
SOVIET REFUSENIK IS NOW A MEMBER
OF ISRAEL'S KNESSET SAID THAT
PUTIN HAS SOUGHT. TO THE STORE
IN IN IN MANIPULATE THE
HOLOCAUST TO JUSTIFY. THIS
ILLEGAL INVASION BABI YAR
HAPPENS TO BE THE SITE WHERE
INTEREST THE COURSE OF TWO DAYS
NOT SEIZE. SHOT AND KILLED
THIRTY FOUR THOUSAND JEWS AND
DROP THEM INTO THE RAVINE WHICH
WAS USED AS A MASS GRAVE FOR THE
ENTIRETY. OF THE WAR OVER A
HUNDRED THOUSAND BODIES
EVENTUALLY WERE IN THAT ROUTINE
BY THE END OF THE WAR SO WE MUST
CALL OUT. THIS ANTI SEMITISM
THAT PUTIN IS PUTTING FORWARD
AND THIS ISN'T SOMETHING THAT'S
JUST IN RUSSIA IT OR JUST ONLY
IN EUROPE IT'S EVERYWHERE. AND
OVER THANKSGIVING FAMILY OF MINE
GOT TOGETHER FOR THE FIRST TIME
IN YEARS FROM THREE DIFFERENT
STATES AND BROUGHT FAMILY
MEMENTOS. TOGETHER AND WE LOOKED
AT THEM OLD PHOTOS. AND I NOW
HAVE MY GREAT GRANDMOTHER
ANNIE'S. NATURALIZATION PAPERS.
FROM THE NINETEEN THIRTIES. AND
SHE CAME FROM THIS PART OF
EUROPE. IN THE UNITED STATES. ON
HER NATURALIZATION PAPERS HAD
HER RACE MARKED ON HER PAPERS
AND HER RACE THEY MARKED WAS
HEBREW. SO LET'S REMEMBER HOW
PEOPLE SEE JEWS AS DIFFERENT
THAN OTHER IN EUROPE AND THIS
EXTENDS FAR BEYOND EUROPE AND
THAT IS STAND UP AND
WHEN IT'S USED THIS ANTI
SEMITISM MISTRUST DISTORTION OF
THE HOLOCAUST WE MUST CALL IT
OUT TO MAKE SURE THAT THIS DOES
NOT BECOME A BIGGER PROBLEM FOR
THE WORLD. THANK YOU. THANK YOU
MISTER MATHIS YOU ARE RECOGNIZED
AT YOUR DESK. THANK YOU MADAM
SPEAKER. I TO RISE IN SUPPORT.
WE ALL MUST STAND WITH THE
SOVEREIGN NATION OF UKRAINE.
THIS IS THE FIRST MILLENNIAL
COMBAT VETERAN. WITH A PURPLE
HEART ELECTED TO STATE OFFICE IN
THE COUNTRY I FIND THIS DEEPLY
DISTURBED. BECAUSE I'VE ACTUALLY
FOUGHT IN COMBAT ON THE GROUND.
I UNDERSTAND WHAT'S GOING ON
THERE BECAUSE I'VE LIVED IT.
COLLEAGUES ARE RIGHT WE HAVE TO
CALL OUT RUSSIA WE HAVE TO CALL
OUT PUTIN. WHAT HE IS DOING IS
AN ABSOLUTE CRIME ON HUMANITY.
THERE'S AN OLD SAYING. IF YOU
WANT PEACE PREPARE FOR WAR. IN
ORDER TO DO THAT. WE HAVE TO
LOOK AT THINGS LIKE ENERGY
INDEPENDENCE. WE HAVE TO MAKE
SURE WE'RE NOT GETTING DIRTY
BLOOD OIL FROM RUSSIA. WHEN WE
CAN DO IT HERE AT HOME CLEANER
AND BETTER THAN THE OTHER GUY.
WE HAVE TO MAKE SURE WE'RE GOING
FOOD SO WE CAN SEND SUPPORT IN
AID. BUT YET WE'RE CUTTING
AGRICULTURAL PRODUCTION. WE HAVE
TO MAKE SURE WE HAVE THE BEST
WHEN IT COMES TO STEM EDUCATION
. SO WE HAVE THE BEST AND
BRIGHTEST MINDS. TO DEAL. WITH
THESE CRAZY DICTATORS LIKE PUTIN. BECAUSE WHEN IT COMES TO WAR.
THE SIDE WITH THE RESOURCES WITH
THE TECHNOLOGY WITH THE FUEL IS
A SIDE THAT WINS. THE VERY
SIMPLE EQUATION. WE CANNOT ALLOW
THIS ATROCITY TO CONTINUE. WE
HAVE TO MAKE SURE WE'RE
PRODUCING HERE AT HOME. THE
OTHER NIGHT. MUCH AS I HATE TO
SAY IT PRESIDENT BIDEN WAS RIGHT
WE HAVE TO DO THIS HERE AT HOME. AND AS WE MOVE FORWARD THIS
YEAR. AS WE ALL STAND. TO UNITE
BEHIND UKRAINE WE HAVE TO THINK
ABOUT WHAT ARE WE DOING HERE IS
A BODY. IS A STATE. IS THE FIFTH
LARGEST. ECONOMY IN THE WORLD.
WHAT ARE WE DOING TO BETTER
SUPPORT OUR ALLIES. TO ENSURE
FREEDOM ABROAD. IF WE TRULY ARE
GOING TO STAND WITH UKRAINE WITH
THE PEOPLE THAT ARE FIGHTING
TOOTH AND NAIL. THAT ARE LOSING
SLEEP. THAT ARE SLEEPING IN COLD
WET MUDDY. SONOMA POSITIONS.
WHAT WE DON'T. I KNOW OUR HEARTS
ARE IN THE RIGHT PLACE. LET'S
MAKE SURE OUR POLICIES GOING
FORWARD AS A STATE BACKUP WHAT
WE'RE SAYING THANK YOU. THANK
YOU MISTER MATHIS DR TWENTY ARE
RECOGNIZED AT YOUR DESK. THANK
YOU MADAM CHAIR AND A COLLEAGUE
SO I ALSO RISE IN STRONG
SUPPORTER OF ALL HR NINETY FOUR-
BY MY COLLEAGUE ASSEMBLY MEMBER
COOLEY. I PERSONALLY THANK YOU
FOR BRINGING IT UP WELL. IN FACT
I AND THE MICE OF. ASSEMBLY
MEMBER COOLEY AND MYSELF FOR
INTRODUCED. SIMILAR RESOLUTION
HRS AND NINETY THREE HOWEVER
THIS IS SUCH A SHAME- RESOLUTION
THAT THE CALIFORNIA LEGISLATURE
WILL CONDEMN FISSURELLIDAE
RUSSIA ALSO AGGRESSION AGHAST UP
AGAINST A PIECE FOR NATION OF-
UKRAINE. THIS IS SAW ARE
UNBELIEVABLE WE KNOW THE WOULD
THE KNOLLS- THIS IS SO OFTEN DAM
. ALL WE NEED TO COME DOWN THAT
THE AGGRESSION AND THAT WE WOULD
NOT ACCEPT THE VIA A BEHAVIOR.
AS WE ALL KNOW THAT THE OWNER-
FEBRUARY TWENTY SECOND OF LET
LET ME ARE POTENT INVADED THE
UKRAINE WITHOUT ANY PROVOCATION
. THIS ACT OF AGGRESSION
AGGRESSION. FOLLOW SUCH A
HISTORY OF ALL ON WARRANTED THE
ACTS OF AGGRESSION BY RUSSIA AND
AGAINST A IS A NEIGHBOR'S
SUBSTANCE IN THE FORM OF A
SOVIET UNION IN NINETEEN EIGHTY
NINE. I DON'T HAVE ANY UPPER
SONORA. RANDALL RELATIVES ARE
LIVING IN UKRAINE HOWEVER THIS
IS A INTO A NATIONAL TRAGEDY.
IMAGINE THAT THE U. S. S. US ON
THE ATTACK THE BY OUR NEIGHBOR
WHAT THE STATUS ALL WE WILL BE.
IF WE ALLOW LET ME UP PUT INTO A
CONTINUING THIS SUCKS SUCCEED ON
HIS AGGRESSION WHAT WILL BE THE
NEXT CHAPTER OF WHAT
INTERNATIONALISTS. JIAN OFFER A
COUNTRY IS ALWAYS JUST SAW.
INVADE THE NEIGHBORS ONE BY ONE.
AND ALL WHAT IS A HAS A
MOTIVATION IS HAS TO RE REBUILD
THE HAS SOLVED EMPIRE ALL FOR
SOVIET UNION WE NORMAL IT IS OUR
INTENT. WE SHOULD ABA ACTED THE
WAY BEFORE WHEN NOT OVER A
HUNDRED THOUSAND TROOPS TO WAR
SURROUNDING UKRAINE. WHAT THE-
GAME WHAT A PLAN PLANNING ONCE
NOT JUST THE FOR EXERCISE OR FUN
IT WAS SOLD ADMIN ON THE WAR
PLANNING TO. ATTACK AND DAHLE
INVADE INTO THE COUNTRY IF THEY
ARE SUCCESSFUL WHAT WILL BE THE
NEXT STEP THAT WE CAN ANTICIPATE
. I'M SURE THAT'LL BE ALL THE
ALLIES ALL OF THE NATO COUNTRIES
SO IT WILL BE UP ON THE THREAT.
OUR SOLDIERS ARE ALREADY THERE
SO THAT IS SO WHAT DOES THAT
MEAN IT. IS A COULD NOT BE OUR-
WHAT WERE THREE. WE ALSO HEAR
ABOUT THE THREAT- BALL NUCLEOLAR
WORSE. THIS IS NOT SOMETHING WE
SHOULD NOT ALLOW IN THE TAKE A
EVEN STRONGER MANAGER. WOW OF
WHY IN THE WORLD IS DONE IN A IN
THIS OUR OUR MARKET THAT WE HAVE
ABUNDANCE OF ALL OUR NATURAL
RESOURCES SO WE BY EVEN AT THIS
MOMENT OF. ALL RUSSIAN NOW WITH
OIL INTO THE U. S. I END UP PAID
THE MONEY TO THAT. WHAT CAN WE
DO. IF A FEDERAL MATTER WE
CANNOT CONTROL DOWN THE
CALIFORNIA SHOULD TOOL. I DON'T
KNOW WHETHER WE SHOULD DO OUR
AMADOR. BILL OR ANOTHER ARE-
FATEMEH SHANINA. WE SHOULD NOT
ADOPT A TOOL BAN ALL TRADE SO
WITH A RUSSIA S. OUT WE BOAST
ABOUT THE WILL CALIFORNIA- SO IF
THE LARGEST SO ECONOMY I'M SURE
WELL WE DO LOTS OF A TRADING
WITH RUSSIA WHAT ACTION HAVE WE
TAKEN WHAT ACTION SHOULD BE
TAKEN THIRTY SEVEN OF THE A LOT
OF ALL OUR LIQUOR SO KNOCK KNOCK
OUT BEING TRADED DOT AND WE
SHOULD BAN THEM. WE SHOULD NOT
THE FUNDED THEY ARE WHAT CHEST I
STRONGLY CONDEMN. ALL WHAT SHOWS
ARE PUTTING SOME OF RESTON INTO
UKRAINE ASK YOUR STRONG
SUPPORTER BY JOHN ON. THE FULL
THANK YOU. MR VOEPEL YOUR AT
YOUR DESK. COLLEAGUES I RISE AND
OF. NINETY FOUR IN OF COURSE
WITH THE LITTLE HISTORY STORY.
THE CRANE GAINED ITS FREEDOM
FROM RUSSIA NINETEEN NINETY ONE. AND THE CURRENT MILITARY
GENERATIONS. I GREW UP IN
FREEDOM. THEY'RE NOT GONNA GO
DOWN. AND HERE'S WHAT'S GOING TO
HAPPEN. I DID TWO COMBAT TOURS
IN VIETNAM AND I NEVER DREAMT
LITTLE RICE FARMERS COULD BE
THIS. SO WHAT YOU MAY SEE IN
UKRAINE. IS THE INVASION OF
AFGHANISTAN BY RUSSIA IN
NINETEEN SEVENTY NINE. THEY WERE
THERE FOR TWENTY YEARS G. DOES
THAT SOUND FAMILIAR. THE
RUSSIANS LOST FIFTEEN THOUSAND
DEAD. AROUND THREE HUNDRED
THOUSAND WOUNDED. AND IT GOT SO
BAD THE RUSSIAN GOVERNMENT WAS
FOR BUILDING FUNERALS. BECAUSE
THEY DIDN'T WANT THAT TO GET OUT
. I THINK UKRAINE MAY HOLD OUT.
WE DON'T KNOW ABOVE MY PAY GRADE
. BUT EVEN IF YOU CRANE FELL THE
WILL FALL. THEY'RE NOT RICE
FARMERS THEY'RE FREE YOUR
CRANIUM FARMERS. THANK YOU. THAT
IS YOUR RECOGNIZED AT YOUR DESK
. THANK YOU MADAM SPEAKER
MEMBERS I AM PROUD TO RISE IN
SUPPORT OF HR NINETY FOUR WHICH
CONDEMNS RUSSIA'S UNPROVOKED
INVASION OF UKRAINE MAKE NO
MISTAKE ABOUT IT YOU CRANE AS A
SOVEREIGN NATION AND HOUTEN'S
THUGGISH ACTIONS AGAINST THE
UKRAINIAN PEOPLE HAVE RIGHTFULLY
DRAWN CRITICISM FROM EVERY
CORNER OF THE FREE WORLD.
CALIFORNIA MUST NOW ADD OUR
VOICE TO THE GROWING COALITION
BY CENSURING RUSSIA AND DOING
WHAT WE CAN TO HELP THE YOUR
CRANIUM PEOPLE. YOUR CRANIUM
THEY'RE STANDING THEIR GROUND ON
THE FRONT LINES OF DEMOCRACY.
EVEN THOUGH AS THIS WAR RAGES ON
THOUSANDS OF MILES AWAY. WE
CANNOT FORGET HOW CLOSE TO HOME
THIS COMPLEX REALLY IS. JUST A
FEW DAYS AGO I SAW A PICTURE OF
A UKRAINIAN WOMAN MOTHER HUDDLED
WITH HER DAUGHTER. DURING THE
RUSSIAN INVASION OF HER CITY.
THE CAPTION READ MY DAUGHTER AND
I SURVIVING THE NIGHT IN UKRAINE
. WE ARE REAL PEOPLE AT WAR.
WITH THIS CRAZY DICTATOR AND WE
NEED THE WORLD'S SUPPORT RIGHT
NOW. THAT NIGHT WHEN I CUDDLED
WITH MY OWN DAUGHTER. AND SHE
FINALLY FELL ASLEEP I COULDN'T
HELP BUT REMEMBER THAT WOMAN.
AND HER DAUGHTER. AND HOW
SIMILAR THEY WERE TO MY FAMILY.
BUT JUST HOW DIFFERENT THEIR
LIVES HAVE BECOME BECAUSE OF A
CONDEMNING ALL OF THAT
CONDEMNABLE ACTIONS OF ONE
TYRANTS. MEMBERS WE LIVE IN THE
GREATEST BLANKET OF LIBERTY AND
FREEDOM. AND UKRAINIANS DESERVE
THE SAME. I URGE YOUR SUPPORT OF
HRNINETY FOUR. THANK YOU
MISSPELLED ADDRESS MR KILEY
RECOGNIZED AT YOUR DESK. THANK
YOU MADAM SPEAKER I I'VE HAD THE
PRIVILEGE OF- REPRESENTING A
REGION THAT HAS AGES TREMENDOUS
COMMUNITY OF UKRAINIAN AMERICANS
AND ATTENDED DOZENS OF OUR
COMMUNITY EVENTS AND OBSERVERS
IS THE CELEBRATIONS I SEE THE
ASSEMBLY MEMBER FROM A RANCHO
CORDOVA AND MANY OF THEM AND-
THE UKRAINIAN AMERICAN COMMUNITY
IS SO IMPORTANT- TO THE FABRIC
OF THE STATE. I RIGHT NOW WE ARE
SEEING ABSOLUTELY HEARTBREAKING
IMAGES- IN UKRAINE IS THE
ASSEMBLY MEMBER JUST DESCRIBE
BUT WE'RE ALSO SEEING INCREDIBLE
DISPLAYS OF COURAGE AND HERE IN
CALIFORNIA WE'RE SEEING PEOPLE
FROM EVERY WALK OF LIFE RALLY IN
SUPPORT OF YOU OUR UKRAINIAN
FRIENDS AND NEIGHBORS. WHAT WE
HAVE WITNESSED IS AN ACT OF
SHEER BARBARISM IT'S AN ATTACK
ON A SOVEREIGN NATION ATTACK ON
A SOVEREIGN PEOPLE MORE THAN
THAT IT'S AN ATTACK ON THE VERY
FOUNDATION OF THE MODERN WORLD
FREEDOM DEMOCRACY. HUMAN RIGHTS
AND IT IS SO IMPORTANT THAT WE
SPEAK IN ONE VOICE IN
CONDEMNATION OF WHAT IS
HAPPENING AND THAT WE USE EVERY
TOOL AT OUR DISPOSAL TO GIVE
THAT CONDEMNATION REAL IMPACT
AND MEANING. AND MOST OF ALL
IT'S IMPORTANT THAT WE SUPPORT
OUR UKRAINIAN FRIENDS AND
NEIGHBORS IN OUR COMMUNITY AND
OFFER THEM EVERY MEASURE OF
SUPPORT AND COMFORT AND FOR THAT
WE CAN. THANK YOU. MR GABRIEL
YOU ARE RECOGNIZED AT YOUR DESK
. THANK YOU MADAM SPEAKER- I
ALSO RISE PROBABLY IN SUPPORT OF
HR NINETY FOUR WANT TO THANK OUR
COLLEAGUE FROM MAJOR CORDOVA FOR
BRING YOUR FOR I'LL BE BRIEF I
DON'T KNOW IF I'VE EVER SAID
THIS BEFORE THE FLOOR BUT I
AGREE WHOLEHEARTEDLY AND IT'S
WHOSE YEAH SICKLY WITH MY
COLLEAGUE FROM SACRAMENTO COUNTY
AND I WANT TO APPRECIATE THIS
RARE. MOMENT OF BIPARTISANSHIP
WHICH I THINK IS SO IMPORTANT.
BECAUSE WHAT WE ARE WITNESSING
IS HE SAID THIS IS NOT JUST AN
ATTACK ON A SOVEREIGN NATION
IT'S NOT JUST AN ATTACK ON A
SOVEREIGN PEOPLE. IN A
DEMOCRACY. THIS IS AN ATTACK ON
THE FUNDAMENTAL WORLD ORDER.
IT'S AN ATTACK ON THE IDEA THAT
COUNTRY SHOULD NEGOTIATE THROUGH
DIPLOMACY. I COME TO AGREEMENTS
AND A CO EXIST PEACEFULLY. THIS
IS THE IDEA THAT VLADIMIR PUTIN
IS ADVANCING THAT BECAUSE HE HAS
POWER. BECAUSE HE HAS AN ARMY
BECAUSE HE FEELS LIKE DOING
SOMETHING THAT HE CAN TAKE OVER
AND OCCUPY ANOTHER COUNTRY. THAT
HE CAN EXERT HIS WELL ON THAT
COUNTRY. AND THIS IS NOT. AS WE
HAVE LEARNED IN HISTORY. WHEN
DICTATORS DO THINGS LIKE THAT.
THEY MUST BE MET WITH STIFF
RESISTANCE. AND I'VE BEEN SO
HARD TO SEE THAT IN. ICONIC
PLACES AROUND THE WORLD LIT UP
WITH THE COLORS OF UKRAINIAN
FLAG. IF I WAS FILLED WITH SUCH
PRIDE ANNOYS WALKING HOME THE
OTHER NIGHT. AND SO ARE CAPITOL
DOME. HERE IN THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA LET UP WITH THE
COLORS OF YOUR TRAINING FRIDAY.
I THINK I HOPE THAT IT SENDS A
MESSAGE OF. ALLY SHIP. AND
REINFORCES THE INCREDIBLE
COURAGE AND STRENGTH AND BRAVERY
THAT WE HAVE SEEN FOR THE
UKRAINIAN PEOPLE. THERE SHOULD
BE NO DOUBT FROM UKRAINIAN
PEOPLE THAT YOUR RESPECTIVE OF
WHERE WE STAND. IN THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA ARE DOMESTIC
POLITICS. WE ARE STANDING
STRONGLY IN SOLIDARITY WITH
THEM. AND WE HAVE BEEN
INCREDIBLY IMPRESSED BY THEIR
BRAVERY AND THE COURAGE AND THE
WILLINGNESS TO STAND UP. TO
INCLUDE INCREDIBLY VICIOUS.
INVADING ARMY. ALSO SUGGEST
EVERYONE HERE NONE OF US WANTS.
WAR NOBODY WANTS A GLOBAL WAR
EVERYBODY WANTS PEACE. BUT I
THINK THAT IT'S VERY IMPORTANT
THAT WE BACK UP OUR WORDS OF
SOLITARY WITH MEANINGFUL ACTION.
IT WAS VERY PROUD TO SEE THE
MEMBERS OF THE LEGISLATURE HAVE
INTRODUCED. LEGISLATION TO USE
OUR ECONOMIC AND A POLITICAL AND
OUR MORAL POWER. TO STAND UP TO
THE PUT REGIME. I WAS HARD TO
SEE THAT OUR GOVERNOR IS
SUPPORTING THOSE EFFORTS. WE
HAVE THE WORLD'S FIFTH LARGEST
ECONOMY AS WAS MENTIONED. WE
HAVE A LARGER ECONOMY THAN
RUSSIA. WE HAVE THE ABILITY TO
THROUGH OUR GLOBAL GLOBAL
LEADERSHIP. TO REINFORCE IN A
VERY SIGNIFICANT WAY U. S. AND
INTERNATIONAL SANCTIONS. I HOPE
THAT IN ADDITION TO THESE
IMPORTANT JUST AS OF SOLITAIRE
THESE IMPORTANT WORDS OF
SOLIDARITY. THAT WE WILL TAKE
MEANINGFUL ACTION. BECAUSE THIS
IS A PIVOTAL MOMENT IN WORLD
HISTORY. AND CALIFORNIA HAS A
PIVOTAL ROLE TO PLAY WITH THAT
AND WITH TREMENDOUS APPRECIATION
FOR THE BRAVERY AND COURAGE OF
UKRAINIAN PEOPLE. RESPECT YOUR
QUESTION I VOTE ON HR NINETY
FOUR. THANK YOU MR GABRIEL
SEEING AND HEARING AT NO FURTHER
DEBATE ASSEMBLY MEMBER COOLEY
YOU MAY CLOSE. CALLERS ARE JUST
THANK YOU ALL FOR YOUR
CONTRIBUTION TO THIS RESOLUTION
YOUR REMARKS- ALL WEEK I'VE HAD
THIS PHRASE IN MY MIND. A LONG
BEGINNING A MOMENT WE DO NOT
ACTUALLY KNOW WHAT IS THE COURSE
OF WHAT WILL TRANSPIRE IN
UKRAINE. WE ONLY KNOW EACH DAY
WE FIND WHAT IS THE LATEST IT IS
THIS LONG BEGIN A MOMENT IT IS A
MOMENT WHERE. I KNOW. SACRAMENTO
COUNTY BUT THROUGHOUT OUR STATE
THROUGHOUT THE WORLD I THINK.
THERE ARE MANY FAITHS. THE
PEOPLE CENTER THEIR LIVES AROUND
. BUT I KNOW FOR ALL OF THEM
THIS IS SURELY A TIME WHEN THEY
SORT OF GO BACK TO THEIR
FOUNDATIONS I THINK ABOUT WHAT
TRULY MATTERS AND- FOR THE
STUDENTS OF THE BIBLE IN THE
UKRAINIAN FAITH. THERE ARE MANY
PHRASES THAT COME TO MIND BUT
THERE'S ONE THAT STANDS OUT YOU
CANNOT ABIDE A SITUATION WHEN
PEOPLE SAY PEACE PEACE BUT THERE
IS NO PEACE. SO I THINK THAT IS
THE MOMENT OF THE MODERN AGE
FINDS ITSELF IN LOOKING AT WHAT
IS TRANSPIRING. NOT WISHING TO
HAVE OUR APCAR APPLE CARTS OF
PEACE UNSETTLED. REALLY SAY WHAT
IS THE PATH OF PEACE. AS A- WE
REMARKED ON THIS FOR IN MANY
DIFFERENT WAYS SO. I REQUEST OF
THE FIRST ROLE BUILDING FOR COAL
AUTHORS I THANK YOU FOR YOUR
SOLIDARITY HERE AND FOR THE-
UNANIMITY OF VIEWS EXPRESSED.
TODAY AND THE PASSION I THANK
YOU ALL. CHRIS THAT I WROTE.
THANK YOU ASSEMBLY MEMBER COOLEY
MEMBERS ASSEMBLY MEMBER COOLEY
HAS REQUESTED THAT THE FIRST
ROLE BE OPENED FOR A CO AUTHORS
THE CLERK WILL OPEN THE ROLE.
THIS ARTICLE. ALL THOSE FOLKS
WHO DESIRE TO VOTE. MEMBERS THIS
IS FOR CO AUTHORS. THE CLERK
WILL CLOSE THE ROLE THERE ARE
SIXTY NINE CO AUTHORS ADDED.
MEMBERS WE WILL NOW TAKE A ROLL
CALL VOTE ON THE RESOLUTION THE
CLERK WILL OPEN THE ROLE. ALL
THOSE VOTER DESIRE TO VOTE. THE
CLERK WILL CLOSE THE ROLE AND
TALLY THE VOTES HIGHS SEVENTY NO
ZERO THE RESOLUTION IS ADOPTED.
WE'LL MOVE ON NOW TO BUSINESS ON
THE DAILY FILE RECONSIDERATION
FILE ITEM ONE SHALL BE CONTINUED
. FILE ITEM TO SHALL BE PASSED
INTERCHANGE FOR THE ASSEMBLY
THIRD READING ON THE SENATE
THIRD READING FILE ITEMS THREE
TO SIX SHALL BE PASSED AND
ROUTINES. MEMBERS WE WILL NOW
MOVE ON TO THE SECOND DAY
CONSENT CALENDAR. THERE ARE
RESOLUTIONS ON TODAY'S CONSENT
CALENDAR BEFORE WE VOTE WILL
FIRST TAKE A FILE ITEM SEVEN TO
TWELVE ON THE CONSENT CALENDAR
FOR THE PURPOSE OF ADDING TO
AUTHORS THE CLERK WILL READ THE
RESOLUTION ON THE CONSENT
CALENDAR. ASSEMBLY CONCURRENT
RESOLUTION ONE FORTY FIVE BY
ASSEMBLY MEMBER REYES RELATIVE
T TRIPLE NEGATIVE BREAST CANCER
HOUSE RESOLUTION NINETY BY
ASSEMBLY MEMBER OLD ON A
RELATIVE TO READ ACROSS AMERICA
DAY. HOUSE RESOLUTION NINETY ONE
BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER MAIENSCHEIN
RELATIVE TO RARE DISEASE DAY
SENATE CONCURRENT RESOLUTION
SIXTY THREE BY CENTER HER TADO
AND OTHERS ROSA TO ROSE AND
GROUPS RECOMMEND RECOGNITION DAY
SENATE CONCURRENT RESOLUTION
SIXTY FIVE BY CENTER RUBIO AND
OTHERS RELATIVE TO TEEN DATING.
VIOLENCE AWARENESS AND
PREVENTION MONTH AND SENATE
CONCURRENT RESOLUTION SIXTY SIX
BY SEVEN DODD AND OTHERS
RELATIVE TO EATING DISORDERS
EATING DISORDERS AWARENESS WEEK
. THE CLERK WILL NOW OPEN THE
ROLE TO ALLOW ANY MEMBERS. ALL
THOSE WHO DESIRE TO BILLS.
MEMBERS THIS VOTE IS FOR CO
AUTHORS. ALL MEMBERS WHO DESIRE
TO VOTE. IF YOU WHIC TO ADD ON
AS A CO AUTHOR TO THE
RESOLUTIONS ON CONSENT PLEASE
VOTE NOW. THE CLERK WILL CLOSE
THE ROLE THERE ARE SIXTY NINE CO
AUTHORS. MOVING ON TO VOTE ON
THE CONSENT CALENDAR. DOES ANY
MEMBER WISH TO REMOVE ANY ITEM
FROM THE CONSENT CALENDAR.
SEEING AND HEARING THEM THE
CLERK WILL READ THE SECOND DAY
CONSENT CALENDAR ASSEMBLY
CONCURRENT RESOLUTION ONE FORTY
FIVE BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER REYES
RELATIVE TO TRACKING STRIPPING
NEGATIVE BREAST CANCER. THE
CLERK WILL OPEN THE ROLE. ALL
MEMBERS VOTE VERY TO VOTE. ALL
MEMBERS VOTE YOU DESIRE TO VOTE
. ALL MEMBERS WHO DESIRE TO GO.
THE CLERK WILL CALL THE ROLL AND
TIE THE VOTES HIGHS SIXTY NINE
KNOWS ZERO THE CONSENT CALENDAR
IS ADOPTED. THE CLERK WILL READ
THE REMAINING ITEMS ON THE
CONSENT CALENDAR HOUSE WAS
RELEASED IN NINETY. FIVE SIXTY
NINE NO ZERO POSSIBLE SOLUTION
NINETY ONE I SIXTY NINE NO ZERO
SENATE CONCURRENT RESOLUTION
SIXTY THREE HI FIFTY NINE OH
ZERO SENATE CONCURRENT
RESOLUTION SIXTY FIVE SIXTY NINE
NO ZERO AND SENATE CONCURRENT
RESOLUTION SIXTY SIX. SIXTY NINE
NO ZERO. WE WANT TO MOVE ON NOW
TO PREVIOUSLY ANNOUNCED
ADJOURNMENTS IN MEMORY THE
QUORUM CALL IS NOT YET LIFTED.
MEMBERS PLEASE TAKE YOUR SEATS
OR TAKE YOUR CONVERSATIONS OFF
THE FLOOR. ASSEMBLY MEMBER
TAKING. HAS BEEN GRANTED PRIOR
PERMISSION TO SPEAK ON AN
ADJOURNMENTS IN MEMORY TODAY.
ASSEMBLY MEMBER CHIANG. THANK
YOU BELT SPEAKER TODAY IT IS MY
HONOR TO REQUEST THAT WE ADJOURN
IN THE MEMORY OF A GREAT SAN
FRANCISCO BUT ALSO GREAT
CALIFORNIA RICHARD BLOW FOR HIS
FRIENDS KNOW HIM DECLINE-
DEPARTMENT I NEVER THINK PLEASE
HOLD FOR ONE MOMENT. THANK YOU
MEMBERS BIGGER. DECLINE WAS BORN
ON JULY THIRTY FIRST NINETEEN
THIRTY FIVE IN SAN FRANCISCO. TO
LEASE VERSION HARPER BLOG. HE
GRADUATED FROM THE UNIVERSITY
CALIFORNIA BERKELEY AND TO THIS
VERY DAY- BLACK GOLD AND BLUE HE
WAS ONE OF OUR- MOST REMARKABLE
WONDERS HAS SERVED THAT
UNIVERSITY CONTRIBUTED TO THE
UNIVERSITY. IT CONTINUED SERVE
UNIVERSITY CALIFORNIA AS A
REJECT ANY HAS DONE SO OVER THE
LAST TWO DECADES IT WAS
CURRENTLY CHAIRMAN EMERITUS OUR
BOARD OF REGENTS. HE WAS THE
FOUNDING MEMBER OF THE BLUM
CENTER FOR DEVELOPING ECONOMIES
AT THE UNIVERSITY CALIFORNIA
BERKELEY A SUPPORTER STUDENTS
LEARNING HOW TO COMPLY. GLOBAL
POVERTY- THAT WAS ONE OF HIS
MANY MANY PASSIONS- TO INSURE
THAT WE NOT ONLY WITHIN OUR OWN
COUNTRY BUT THAT WE FOUND A WAY
TO WORK HELP OTHER DEVELOPING
COUNTRIES. ONE OF HIS CLOSEST
RELATIONSHIPS WAS WITH THE DALAI
LAMA. AND AS SOMEBODY WHO WAS
THERE- YOU SUPPORT PEACE IN THAT
REGION I HE FOUNDED THE AMERICAN
HIMALAYAN FOUNDATION. HE WORKED
THERE TO IMPROVE HEALTH CARE AND
HUMAN TRAFFICKING PROVIDE ELDER
IN CHILD CARE REALLY PROMOTE
THAT REGENTS. VERY VIBRANT
CULTURE. HE HAS SERVED- MANY
MANY U. S. PRO FOR JIMMY TO.
BILL CLINTON AS WELL AS TO WHAT
PRESIDENT OBAMA I AM WAS A
MEMBER OF THE PRESIDENT'S GLOBAL
DEVELOPMENT COUNCIL. HE IS ALSO
VERY WELL KNOWN IN OUR TOWN OF
BEING THE SPOUSE OF SENATOR
FEINSTEIN. HE WAS JUST AN
AMAZING MEMBER OF OUR COMMUNITY
MADE SO MANY CONTRIBUTIONS NOT
JUST TO THE UNIVERSITY BUT
REALLY TO THE CITY. AND COUNTY
OF SAN FRANCISCO AS WELL AS TO
OUR COUNTRY INSURGENTS SO MANY.
DIFFERENT CAPACITIES THIS IS A
MAJOR LOSS NOT JUST FOR OUR
STATE REALLY- FOR THE ENTIRE
NATION. IN ADDITION TO MISS. THE
TO SENATOR FEINSTEIN. MR BONTA
SURVIVED BY A BROTHER ROBERT HIS
DAUGHTERS AND THAT HEIDI AND
EILEEN. STEPDAUGHTER CATHERINE
AND SEVEN GRANDCHILDREN. I'D
LIKE TO ASK YOU TO PLEASE JOIN
ME IN A JOINING IN HIS MEMORY.
THANK YOU ASSEMBLY MEMBER TANK.
MEMBERS IN THE ABSENCE OF
OBJECTION THE QUORUM CALL IS
LIFTED. MEMBERS PLEASE BRING THE
NAMES TO THE DESK TO BE PRINTED
IN THE JOURNAL ALL REQUEST TO
ADJOURN IN MEMORY. WILL BE
DEEMED READ AND PRINTED IN THE
JOURNAL. THE SESSION SCHEDULE IS
AS FOLLOWS FRIDAY MARCH FOURTH
NO FLOOR SESSION IT NO CHECK IN
SESSION. MONDAY MARCH SEVENTH
FLOOR SESSION AT ONE PM. ALL
OTHER ITEMS REMAINING WILL BE
PASSED AND RETAINED ALL MOTION
SHALL BE CONTINUED. SEEING AND
HEARING NO FURTHER BUSINESS I AM
READY TO ENTERTAIN A MOTION TO
ADJOURN. MISS REYES MOVES MR
GALLAGHER SECONDS THAT THIS
HOUSE STANDS ADJOURNED UNTIL
MONDAY MARCH SEVENTH AT ONE PM.
STANDING.